all right so as Jamie mentioned I'm a
certified Mathematica trainer I've
worked in academia for many years and
I've I've talked to people so far quite
a bit where they're experimenting with
Mathematica online and getting a feel
for what it does but especially making
that transition from desktop to putting
things on the web or or doing new things
that could they could never do with
Mathematica before because this
technology opens up new avenues so let's
get started okay
all right so I think in terms of of the
benefits of mathematic online a lot of
times it boils down to workflow and and
that's what I'm going to focus in on a
lot today where if you want to take
notebooks and and share them with a
broader audience in in some way shape or
form there's several ways to do that but
a lot of you know a lot of the benefits
to Mathematica online it boils down to
this workflow so so far I've seen two
broad types of workflows when people
used mathematic online or Wolfram cloud
the first is called more of a deployment
so the idea is you are embedding
mouse-driven applications into existing
web content so meaning if you've got a
website that is a course website or a
research website or just a personal
interest website but you want to embed
some sort of live calculation in that
into existing web content that's a great
fit for it for what we call a deployment
Wolfram language can now do full web
forms so I'll show this in a little bit
but this takes the tedium out of
switching back and forth between us
versus HTML versus other web
technologies just to build a web wrapper
for some sort of calculation or
something that you want to share so
there's a very easy convenient way to do
that now third type of deployment I've
seen a lot is notebooks those of you
familiar with CDF this is similar to CDF
but with the main difference being
things live in browser instead of living
as a local file or a file that needs a
local piece of software to run
so a typical notebook that lives as a
deployment it would have text and
formulas and graphics and calculations
so all the usual things that notebooks
are good for the live calculations
though are most driven in applications
so again it's something where people
read this full document but then they
can do some live calculations with a
slider or something like that on the
other hand or on the other end of the
pool there are what we call just sharing
full notebooks so while a deployment is
more sharing a finished application or a
finished project sharing a full notebook
opens up the authoring environment and
is a much more live editable mathematica
like wolfram notebook environment so if
you share wolfram notebook with other
mathematica online users they can change
the inputs they can append to it it's a
living breathing document so this is
nice if you're collaborating with
someone it's nice if you share in
courseware it's nice if you want to give
someone a start of a project and then
have them append to it it's also nice I
mean I'm going to talk about sharing and
in collaboration most of the time but
just the idea of using Mathematica
online where if you go to a machine like
a guest machine or a collaborators
machine they don't have the full
Mathematica on that machine it is really
convenient just to hop over there and
log in and change and work in a full
notebook without going through the the
prerequisite step of a full installation
other things for full notebooks I mean
there are specific viewers and
collaborators and ways to do this so
unlike a deployment where the the
delivery mechanism is is usually pretty
straightforward it's it's a website
whether it's a third party or our
website there are more workflows and
more workflow possibilities that you
will want to do with full notebooks so
meaning you might want to give a
notebook to someone but have it not be
editable or
you might want to give a notebook to
someone but have forced them to create
their own copies so that they can append
to it but they don't disturb your
original work especially with courseware
and especially with things on the other
hand with a research team you might have
a team of three or five people you're
each building part of an algorithm or
part of a program and you all want to
pop in at different times to depend to a
different section of the same notebook
but everyone can see everyone else's
work as different people are popping in
at different times so when you start to
talk about full notebooks the workflow
and and what you want to do and what you
expect to do out of that is different so
I'm gonna delve into that a little bit
as well but this is a broad outline for
how this technology is used in and what
I'm going to show today okay so let's
start with model building in Mathematica
so when I talk about deployment so I'm
gonna start with deployments when I talk
about deployments we're just going to
quickly build something here to actually
deploy so if we start with something
like importing a logo so we're gonna
import this off the web I'm gonna define
a variable called logo this is just our
Wolfie logo off of the Wolfram website
so if we import that and then we say
let's blur that
so let's you know let me just blur that
the that's the beauty of Wolfram
language I don't need to explain any
further of what this does it's pretty
straightforward what it's doing so in
terms of model building then we might
want to take the next step and we might
want to say instead of blurring to some
sort of constant second argument we can
wrap a manipulate around this blur so we
are increasing or decreasing the amount
of the amount of blur that we apply to
this image so manipulate has been around
a long time this is this is not the
focus of this this actual talk but
manipulate is something that a lot of
users make heavy heavy use of across
fields across
academia hobbyist projects industry so
this is why I'm starting with this as a
representative example so one we blur a
logo like this the next thing now that I
want to talk about in in the way of
deployments is how do we share this as a
deployment and really start to get this
on the web
so if we start with blurring logo and we
add a little bit here
save definitions true so that what that
means is we are storing the definition
of our variable in the GUI itself we can
start with that and then there's a nice
new function and Wolfram language called
cloud to play so when I run cloud to
play instead of get him getting a GUI
back what I'm getting is a URL this is
doing a lot of things at once so what
cloud deploy does is it takes my
application here albeit a very simple
one with one function but it's taking my
application it's copying it to the
Wolfram servers so my custom code is
copied to the Wolfram servers it links
it up to a Wolfram language kernel on
Wolfram servers it generates a URL it
gives me a slash objects slash coded
encoded URL here so I get a URL that's
very specific to my particular example
and then there's another argument a
second argument to cloud deploy where I
can specify permissions I'll talk about
this a little bit more when we get into
notebooks but here in this case what I'm
just saying is anyone who has this URL
can go in and run this and and it's open
to everyone so when I click on this this
will open on the web this is a
completely now web browser-based version
there's no plugin that's needed there's
no Mathematica kernel that's needed you
know I happen to have you can see here I
happen to have several Mathematica on
this machine but it's not using any of
them so I could send this to all all
attendees here at this webinar or I
could send this to all my friends
they don't need to have Mathematica they
don't need to have Wolfram language they
can just go to this URL they can run my
application and the calculations all
happen on the server so this is a very
very quick and easy way to share an
application where it is portable it
works on any type of web enabled device
in all the system administration of
getting it on the web or hosting it or
doing something that all just takes care
of itself basically all right so once
you have something on the web there's a
lot of things that you can do with it I
mentioned portability before one thing
that you might want to do is embed this
in a course management system so I just
chose one I mean not at random but kind
of at random where you can I frame in
web content into a course management
system a lot of times there is a GUI to
do that in a course management system
where you just say I want to specify a
URL and either want that to open in a
new tab or I want that to be embedded
right here so in this case you can
choose embedded and then it just works
within your CMS this is a screenshot so
I can't move the actual slider here
that's just for demonstration purposes
but same story on something mobile so if
I were to send this URL to someone and
they go on their phone and open it up
and take a look at it they can move the
slider it all works on mobile just fine
it all works on tablet just fine where
they can move the slider so again the
portability of putting live calculations
that are created very very quickly and
very easily but having that accessible
across any web enabled device it is
really really useful and really
interesting and once you start to delve
into this world you get a lot of new
ideas there's a lot of new things you
can do outside of a full complete
Mathematica or Wolfram language
installation
right so the next thing now so I've used
manipulate to create a deployment where
all I've done is I've wrapped manipulate
around it and it made a slider web forms
are the slightly more general version of
that so instead of it always being a
slider what web what what we're going to
do is we're going to make a webform with
some input fields some more flexibility
some more options for the user of the
application to to change things and to
do things so the again the main way to
do this is cloud deploy but instead of
manipulate what I'm gonna do is use a
function called form page form page asks
what kind of input you want in the form
and then it is what calculation you want
to do with the form so here I'm saying
the input is going to be a PNG file and
then we're going to take that and we're
going to blur that file sorry blur that
image blur that PNG image so when I run
this I get a cloud object again instead
of there being a slider again this
builds an entire web interface there's a
way to drag-and-drop or click and get an
image and then we hit submit for that so
I'm gonna scoot that down just a little
bit and go back to this there we go okay
so now if I drag my wolfie from the
desktop so I drag that right into the
webform and I hit submit and now it has
blurred the image and it's returned it
and again this is a self-contained
program now so I could send this to
anyone they can take whatever image they
want and upload it doesn't have to be
you will see it can be anything and then
it blurs that image and and gives it to
them so again this is a slightly more
general version it's not hard-coded just
one image it's now an application that's
flexible enough to accept any image
next thing that we can do is we can
expand this further where instead of the
one input being an image we can have a
second input where we can increase or
decrease the amount of blur that is
applied to this so when I run this there
instead of there being one image file
input there are actually two inputs here
so again I can drag my image this is
what I want to blur and then I want to
apply a lot of blur to this so I'm going
to submit and then I get a lot of blur
if I want less blur I can run it again
and hit submit and then we can hardly
notice the there's a very subtle blur
that is that is applied there so this is
just a quick example of multiple inputs
here so now I'm actually controlling
what image the my custom program
operates on and then I'm controlling a
parameter of the program itself of the
actual I mean a algorithm is a little
bit too strong of a word but the
algorithm that I am defining here the
program that I'm defining I'm actually
changing the program itself or the user
can change both of those so that's
pretty neat it's another level of
flexibility and level of control for the
users so so far we've done images and
just applying the images we can also do
this with Excel files so if we do oh
gosh
we've pasted this in okay
hmm I seem to be having
difficulties here with the with the
presenter tools that seems to be tasting
in a weird spot anyway there are several
ways that you can expand web forms this
example expands and goes to a
spreadsheet and so rather than doing an
image you can do a spreadsheet but the
web forms are flexible it's not just
images that's the meta point emitting
hitting here but I'm gonna move on and
show a more involved example instead
okay so when people work in Mathematica
or in Wolfram language people get very
used to a nice notebook workflow so I
have I'm gonna highlight a few examples
here from a Wolfram blog from one of our
image processing developers this is a
typical workflow where when people are
building up visualizations or building
up course examples or or building up
something that you want to explore there
is a nice bit by bit by bit build up
that you can do in a notebook where you
can explain things progressively and
it's all outlined very sensibly in a
notebook so in this case what the
notebook is going to do and what the
example is going to do we're going to
start with this image which is a like a
slide at like a cell slide here where we
start with this image and what we want
to do is count these cells in the image
we want to know how many of these are
there's several ways to do this or
several reasons to do this so you might
be working in a research group where you
are a very good worth Wolfram language
programmer you're working with a lot of
different technicians where they don't
want to dive into the language but they
want to use a program that you have
created and developed they don't want to
install the full Mathematica they just
want to take 20 of these cell slides per
day and count them that's what they want
to do so in this case what we're doing
is building up a program that does that
and I'm gonna compare contrast the
notebook way to do that versus a
deployment so starting with a notebook
we can define this as a variable so
we've got that image represented here
then we can start to do some
segmentation analysis so we're starting
to delve into the image processing
functionality in Wolfram language where
we can color this black and white more
easily count the count the cells whoops
I've gone ahead here so I need to make
this just a touch
smooch smaller here there we go that's
much better
okay so now we can make this black and
white to start to do some segmentation
analysis we can start to color the
different unique areas so here what
we're doing is we are counting the major
unique regions this takes a little bit I
guess but what we're going to do is take
all of these different regions that are
different size and we're just going to
color them differently there we go
okay so now we can see there's a unique
color for each unique region so now
we're starting to count the cells we're
starting to visualize this and then now
what we can do is start to label and
really start to visualize this so here
instead of a different color we're gonna
give each a different number and
actually number the cells and make us
put a circle around them so now we can
see our little program does count this
does count this does not count some of
these cells in the corner so then we can
refine and figure out exactly what we
want our program to do so where we're
headed in the right direction here the
other thing that you might want to do is
some statistics so once we start
counting things you might want to do a
histogram where we simply look at the
pixel counts and see what are the common
regions where there's some outliers of
pretty big cells some outliers that are
pretty small a lot of them fall in this
region but you know some sort of pretty
regular pattern here with a with a gap
there so the scientifically that might
mean something and it might be a real
nice discovery basically
but big picture this is sort of the end
of a really nice notebook workflow where
we are in local Mathematica we're
building up a computation step by step
what we have arrived at here is a nice
set of examples that counts these counts
these cells and then gives us a nice
histogram where it's a nice
visualization so let's compare contrast
that with a deployment so if we want to
give this to someone that does not use
Wolfram language does not have
Mathematica installed doesn't really do
much of anything with the language or
hasn't gotten into it yet what we can do
is wrap all of what I just did into a
form function so this looks like a lot
at at first glance but all of this stuff
here in the middle is precisely the same
as what I just did in the notebook so if
you want to make this transition from a
local notebook into a deployment the
transition is is a lot of times fairly
straightforward so all I've done is wrap
this into one compact and and compound
cell sorry that's the word I'm looking
for where I have all the different
calculations separated by a semicolon to
suppress the output in in parentheses
here and then I have wrapped form
function around it so form function is
going to allow us to upload a PNG file
of the cell culture we can have a second
parameter that adjusts the actual
histogram we're going to deploy it to
the cloud we're going to make the
permissions public and so again it's it
looks like a lot but really it is
precisely the same as what I was doing
before and when we run this so we get
this spot with the PNG image let me
there we go let me drag this off the
desktop so now I've uploaded the cell
culture I can adjust the bin width for
the histogram so I'm specifying the
quantity of pixels that I want the bins
to be for the histogram
I run this and the same thing is
happening so when I deployed this to the
cloud it took my 10 line program it
copied it to Wolfram servers it linked
it to a Wolfram kernel so now I'm in
Wolfram cloud slash objects this is my
own URL you can send this to anyone and
then they can upload their cell slide
run the algorithm they get the numbering
they get the histogram and it's a really
nice little dashboard for them to run
this algorithm and really understand
what's going on with their scientific
experiment so I would say that a lot of
times when you see cloud deploy and when
you see it it is in relation to
manipulate but I include this example
just as a good a good way to show how
this scales so rather than just working
with one-liners this can work with a
very nice custom visualization that does
something does something really useful I
mean something useful in the real world
where you could build up this algorithm
and and give it B to people and it's a
nice piece of software for them
basically ok so so in terms of
deployments I have talked about wrapping
cloud deploy around to manipulate and
I've talked about web forms in both
cases we are using Wolfram language to
copy things to our servers and we're
using Wolfram language to put a web
wrapper around our program and it's
hosted on the Wolfram websites there are
other cases and especially if you are a
programmer by trade there are other
cases where you might want to mix and
match languages or you might not want to
use Wolfram language as the creator for
you know for your actual program so
rather than using form function or form
pains you can switch to a cloud deploy
of what we call an API function so this
creates something a bit different so
this is now a restful api that you can
now access and
take a look at so one way to access this
that's pretty simple is just to take
this URL here and do question mark x
equals five so when I run this this will
open a browser and it will run my API
with an input of five so all my all my
API does is it it accepts an integer and
in it squares it so in terms of what
this is actually doing we get 25 back so
again it's a somewhat simple example but
this is somewhat flexible or pretty
flexible as well where if you want to
integrate this into a different language
so rather than referencing this just as
a pure pure URL with a question mark
there is a function called embed code so
switching from cloud deploy to embed
code and what embed code allows you to
do is it gives you a wrapper for a lot
of different languages to reference this
API so if we take the same API which is
just squaring in integer and we say give
me a Java wrapper for this what we get
back is a lot of Java code so the core
of this again is this URL where it's a
Wolfram cloud comm slash objects my
custom URL here but then this is a bit
of Java code that I can plop into a
program and when I run this the program
hits our servers it passes whatever
input parameters you define in your Java
program our servers run that it returns
it but it returns it and it's a way to
embed our code into whatever language
you are are using and again I'm
describing things in terms of Wolfram
language functions which is always it is
a habit of mine but it's it's again
embed code does just what it says it
does it embeds code if you want to do if
you want to embed in languages other
than Java we have several that are
defined and built-in so something like R
or PHP or JavaScript Java HTML
so web languages but also things like
Scala Visual Basic Swift you know more
app development something like that or
Android or lower levels C C++ C sharp
etc so all of these embed code
environments are second-second arguments
to the embed code function where it
gives you that wrapper to call the API
function but the wrapper is specific to
these languages so I'm showing Java but
there are several languages that are
available depending on what you're doing
and what projects you're doing and you
know what what languages you know okay
so that's a good crash course of
deployment so I mentioned at the
beginning deployments are great for
finished projects so if I'm writing a
visualization or a simulation or a model
or an API something that is fairly
specific a finished project deployments
are great for that you can also though
deploy full notebooks so rather than
this being bite-sized web forms or
bite-sized manipulates that are you
embed in the web when you deploy a full
notebook then you get all the nice
examples and explanation and in format
of a notebook so this is one of my
favorite examples Stephen Wolfram
created this it is a cloud notebook on
the central limit theorem it is fairly
long and fairly involved it's a good
it's a good real-world mock-up this
lives on Wolfram cloud comm slash
objects so this is a deployed notebook
where I can look there's some Wolfram
language code there's some
visualizations there's some different
examples there's an embedded manipulate
here where I can move the slider and
there we go okay
it's taking a little while for this to
load because I'm doing the screen share
at the same time and doing audio at the
same time but now when I change this
parameter what I'm doing is increasing
or decreasing the sampling of random
real numbers and creating a histogram of
that and so it's a it's a nice example
of how the histogram smooths out with
with a higher quantity of sampled random
real points but anyway zooming out again
this is a good example of something that
I could send to colleagues or Stephen
Wolfram could send to me where I could
read this and learn about the central
limit theorem I can read his explanation
I can see his calculations which are all
pretty straightforward I can look at
this manipulate and play with this
myself so it's very engaging and then
work through this to really understand
this so this is deployed as a cloud
notebook so how did he do this so I I
recreated his steps here I don't know
precisely how he did this but recreating
his steps a lot of times when you want
to deploy a notebook on the web many
times you're starting from local
Mathematica and there's a really good
connection and interchange between a
local Mathematica installation versus
Mathematica online and getting things in
the cloud so if you start from a local
Mathematica file you can go to file and
then save to Wolfram cloud so if you're
logged into local Mathematica it's the
same login as Mathematica online and
there is shared cloud storage so if you
saved a Wolfram cloud what that is doing
in a nutshell is taking your notebook
and putting it in that shared cloud
storage then if you log into Mathematica
online there are nice gooeys drop-down
menus to publish notebooks so once this
central limit theorem notebook is
uploaded and you log into Mathematica
online and open it you can click on the
publish drop-down menu and then there
are some choices where you can
automatically assign a URL you can allow
access allow anyone access you can
password protect it and then you can
make the controls interactive that means
the slider that I was moving that
sampled more or less random real numbers
but that's live for whoever gets this
URL and whoever wants to run it and then
when I hit publish I get a URL and it is
the URL that I clicked on to start this
example so if you've got notebooks that
you've created in local Mathematica and
you are especially if you're familiar
with the CDF technology so if you want
to do something that is like CDF where
it is a document that you want to send
people with some finished applications
some sliders but available to a wide
audience whether they've got Mathematica
or not or Mathematica online or not this
is a great new way to do this in terms
of advantages over CDF I think CDF is
great because it it is a installation
that includes a big chunk of Mathematica
so if you collaborate with people and
send them a CDF file that's a that's a
really cool way to do it the big
advantage here is the person running
your example does not need to install
CDF there the uptick or the prep to look
at your example is pretty much zero they
just click on a URL they can look at it
immediately the barrier of entry or the
prep that they need to do is is pretty
minimal
that's a big deal when you want to grab
someone's attention or have them read
something if you just want to send them
something and say hey read this for
three minutes you don't want them to
spend double that installing software
this is a big portability benefit where
people can look at this and pop in very
easily and read what you've done but
anyway this is the workflow to take a
notebook and publish it where the full
notebook itself is a deployment so then
that leads us to the the original
division that I made between deployments
and full nope
so once you're looking at a full
notebook and once you're looking at
something with inputs it is awful
tempting to want to go in and change
this random real input and rerun this or
append to this or do something with this
and that's really where deployments end
and mathematic full notebooks and
Mathematica online begins so in addition
to the publish drop-down menu there is a
share menu so if you are collaborating
with other people that have Mathematica
online which many people do these days
it is starting to be added to campus
site licenses in a pretty mainstream way
and it's also starting to be the default
yearly maintenance for licenses as well
so a lot of people now whether you
realize it or not a lot of people have
access to this licensing so sharing is
different than deployment so deployment
you get a URL back you send the URL to
people sharing you are typing in wolfram
IDs of other Mathematica online users
and then they get access to your
notebook so there's a drop-down menu
where you can say your notebook is
private you want to share with some
people they can view they can edit you
can add a personal message and then an
email automatically gets kicked out to
them that prompts them to log into
Mathematica online and they can click on
a button and say great I can look at
your example so there's a nice
mouse-driven GUI way to do that in
Mathematica online however if you're
collaborating with quite a few people
there's often a need to - - well if
you're collaborating with a lot of
people there's a need to not retype
Wolfram IDs over and over and over again
that's essentially where I'm going with
this so especially if you're teaching a
class so if you want to have a course
roster of 50 students and you want to
share a different notebook with them
every week it is tedious to retype those
50 names into the share dialog and
every time you want to share a notebook
so what we've done here is we've gosh
why is this pasting at the end okay I'm
just gonna sort of ignore this and go on
here so what we've done here is created
and I say we as the Wolfram developers I
am NOT able from developer but what what
is built into the Wolfram language is a
whole system to share but shared a
language level the entire advantage to
this is workflow and quantity of people
so if I run the command create
permissions group here I can give it a
name
Kelvin collab and there are two members
of this group two members is not very
exciting but what this could be instead
is your class roster of 50 students or
it could be 20 collaborators on an
assembler once you create this
permissions group it is defined in our
cloud so this name is defined and is
stable and then you can run the command
permissions group just to see it any
time so if I created this permissions
group a long time ago oh I'm sorry this
is that actual output not the input so
if I want to do something with this
permissions group I can start to query
who's in the group I can add people to
the group I can take people out of the
group but what we want to do then is
take this permissions group and start to
use it in a similar way to that share
drop-down menu so what the shared
drop-down menu did was you start with a
notebook and you type in a Wolfram ID
such that they can start to use it set
options is the language way to do this
so instead of logging into Mathematica
going in navigating to that notebook
opening in it clicking on a drop-down
menu instead of doing all that you can
just do set options of this cloud
notebook so this is a optical illusion
notebook that I've created somewhere
along the line
it lives in my Wolfram cloud account so
I referenced that as a cloud object and
then earlier I was doing permissions
goes to public that means anyone can
look at my website the things that I was
creating here I'm specifying this
permissions group and I'm saying anyone
can read and write to this so both of my
two members here whereas I yeah so
Calvin M and Calvin underscore each of
them can open up this notebook each of
them can read but both of them can
actually write and write to the same
notebook so this is good for a research
group where and and again it I've
mentioned this in the beginning but a
research group where if we were working
on this project there were three to five
people each building a separate piece of
the project everyone needs to see what
everyone else is doing if different
people are popping in at different times
but we are all essentially editing the
same notebook this would be the way to
do that it's a very handy way to do that
now conversely if you're teaching a
class and you want to assign something
to students where it's more of a project
this is pretty much the last thing that
you want to do so this is the polar
opposite where this would be a notebook
where it is a start of a project it is
the setup to an assignment but the idea
is that students each complete the
assignment maybe they turn it in
maybe they share it back to you maybe
they don't but in this case we can set
the permissions group where this would
be a course roster we have set it where
they can only read my copy my as the
instructor my copy of the file so they
cannot edit the template the starting
point of the assignment which is very
important and then the second thing
there's an extra argument here called
Auto copy so when students open this
notebook that forces them to create
their own copy in their own cloud
account so if I if this were an
assignment that I shared with
these students they each open it up they
each then create their own corresponding
copy of this they can start to append to
it they can complete the project but no
none of the 50 students can see what the
other 49 students are doing and none of
the 50 students can overwrite my
template that I'm sharing with all the
students so in this case it really
forces students to do their own thing
which in in a in a course setting
especially is extremely important
otherwise it would be it would be
essentially a mass chaos if all the
students were writing over each other
and seeing what each is doing and things
like that so set options is very useful
where if there's a larger group and if
you want to do this repeatedly where it
is this blur logo notebook this week
optical illusion next week another one
next week you can set up as instructor
or as the initiator of the share you can
set up these commands and then just run
them over and over and over so my
permissions group persists as long as I
have a cloud account and maybe next
semester I might change that group based
on a new group of students but for the
most part I can just rerun this based on
the next assignment and once I've done
the prep one time then I'm ready to go
and I can share a lot of projects with
students or I can share a lot of project
with collaborators in a in a hurry once
I've set this up once so the
repeatability is the advantage of the
language as is the groups where you can
do this with a large number of students
basically okay so let me show here one
example so I mentioned before that when
you run the shared drop-down menu or
when you run the command in the language
called cloud share so cloud share is
similar to set options but the
difference is these functions kick out
an email to the recipient of the
notebook so I just want to mention this
briefly
they're pros again their workflow pros
and cons to this so from my personal use
of Wolfram language this is wonderful
for me so if I've got a collaborator and
I want to share a notebook with them or
if I have a group and I want to share a
notebook with them this generic wolfram
mathematica message where the recipient
gets this and sees Calvin Michaud just
shared this with you click to view this
file the recipient logs in as a
mathematic online user and then they can
look at the file and append to it and
work with it that's wonderful there are
other cases though especially if you're
teaching a course where you don't want
this Auto email to go out you might want
to customize this set options does not
kick out an email so if you want to have
that URL linked in a course management
system or a learning management system
and they get the link that way basically
where the CMS LMS gives no link that's a
good way to do it so set options is a
good way to do it you can also do things
like use functions like send mail so you
can use set options to give a group of
50 students permission to access a
notebook you can turn on the auto copy
so that they're gonna make their own
copy but then if you want this message
to say this project is due September 5th
there are no extensions I expect X Y & Z
take a look at your syllabus for more
details like if there's something that
is very specific and very course
specific where this this catch-all
message simply will not do it's not
specific enough
there are ways in language to use send
mail where you can send a URL to that
group of 50 students again if you've got
a permissions group you've got their
emails it's very easy to shoot out an
email to all 50 of them with that URL
with very specific instructions so in
terms of communication this this starts
to be a subtle topic but I want to just
at least start you down the path of
thinking about once you get these things
once
you get full notebooks on the web and
once you start sharing with students
that experience of the right
communication and the right instructions
coming along with the notebook that
becomes very important or the right
wrapper for your your research
collaborators where you want them to do
something specific so in this in this
case they don't learn what part of the
project you want them to do so you might
want to do that but anyway big picture
meta point here is some of these
functions kick out an honor message some
do not both are useful and unlikely both
are useful in different cases basically
okay so that basically brings us to the
end so in conclusion here local
notebooks are still very useful as a
company Wolfram research is not phasing
back or phasing out local notebooks
Mathematica as a local installation and
Mathematica online as a cloud
installation the pair of them will still
be far more useful than either of them
individually but this this new way to
get deployments on the web and notebooks
on the web it opens up new workflows
it's good for web-centric collaboration
I've listed out my email here if you
want to know whether your organization
has Mathematica online please do feel
free to send me an email I'm probably
gonna likely introduce you to the person
who knows the answer to that question
but when you're watching this I can
anticipate that that might be your first
question which is do I have a login to
Mathematica online because a a good
chunk of what I've shown here really
does need some sort of cloud product to
work and into working and to make it
sing for your classes